hi my name is nash grier my favorite
movie is casino
I grew up in Charlotte North Carolina I
talked to my dad all the time about
movies and his favorite movies growing
up and what I should watch and and you
know some of his favorite flicks and
he's put me on some amazing movies that
were before my time while I was watching
casino if it was just like on my chair
the whole time sweating like so into it
the way that it was like crafted and put
together it was like someone was reading
a book almost oh it was so good
that whenever I bet I could change the
odds for every bookmaker in the country
I had created small pieces of what a
story's before and like to see someone
do it on that big of a scale and tell a
story like that was was very inspiring
one second there narrating a scene it's
you know like so beautifully shot and
then they just come right out of the
narration into their own voice and
they're acting in it you only exist out
here because of me
it's super fun to watch because you can
put yourself in those shoes not as an
actor but just as a person and then
think like what would this situation be
like every time I meet somebody the big
question is do I know you I definitely
have had some friendships where like
we've been best friends and I'm like guy
there's no way that we're not ever gonna
be best friends and then you know the
next day they're just gone and I
definitely see that in casino
my own life trust friendship and family
are like three of the most important
things and I definitely have a lot of
trust one of my family and my friends
and you know I only give that if it's
receiving but then you know I'm not just
doing it alone I have my friends with me
and I have them to help me you know
shape Who I am and make decisions with
me and we're all kind of doing this
together the biggest way I relate to the
movie is in the risks that I took in the
risks that everyone took in the film
first of all going from New York to Las
Vegas to do anything is a very big
switch up and the same thing from North
Carolina to Los Angeles so I can relate
in the fact that we flew thousands of
miles to a new spot it was so scary like
because you're basically betting on
yourself and I had it down so cold then
I was given paradise in there I was
working in a completely new environment
and becoming passionate about something
that I was not passionate about the
force I think I related to Sam in that
way because you see throughout the movie
how much he loves to actually be a
casino man
I've been called a lot of things before
like a digital influencer social media
person guy makes videos buying YouTube
person whatever it is you know and I
want to eventually you know put my own
stories on paper and take them from
words to a vision I wanna captivate
people so that's why I love movies hello
I'm Ashley and I love movies that's a
wrap guys
you